we knew that we were being hunted by the
special branch of secret police and also
by MI5 we were pretty high level targets
at that point so we knew the extent of
the resources they could use against us
we knew that the flat was probably
bugged electronic communications were
bugged computers phones that sort of
thing
um we knew there was a possibility we
might be followed around on the streets
and we also knew there was a possibility
that some of our friends would be
recruited to report back on us
I was born and raised in a little island
called Guernsey which is part of the
Channel Islands off the coast of France
British but very close to France I got a
scholarship to a public school and then
I got a scholarship to Cambridge so I
ended up having quite a sort of um Elite
type education I suppose it's best for
putting it
what was your career path what did you
want to do
go to Cambridge and it's sort of an ends
to a means really it's the sort of
golden ticket into the British
establishment if you want it I quite
fancy being a diplat when I was young
and applied to the foreign office and
then I had a letter from the ministry of
Defense allegedly saying there may be
other jobs you'd find more interesting
please call this number
so I did and um then got involved in a
very long recruitment process and 10
months later I found myself walking
through the front door of MI5 to start
work there as an intelligence officer so
in the UK um there are three main
intelligence agencies
first of all is MI5 which is officially
known as the UK domestic Security
Service which is there to protect us
against threats within this country
counter-espionage counterterrorism that
sort of thing there is MI6 which is
officially known as the secret
intelligence service that's the sort of
James Bond foreign intelligence agency
and there's also the government
Communications Headquarters gchq which
is based down in Cheltenham and that is
the listening post it eavesdrops on all
of us and it's a very strange feeling to
have access to all this secret
information you know you're reading
people's private Communications or you
are briefing and debriefing human agents
who are infiltrating groups or you are
tasking mobile surveillance officers or
Statics surveillance officers to spy on
people and it feels really odd to begin
with but actually within a few months it
becomes perfectly normal that's just a
day job
the other big thing though when you join
something like MI5 is that even during
the recruitment process you are not
allowed to tell people where you're
being recruited so we were allowed to
tell our partners or very close family
or our best friends if we trusted them
that was it
so MI5
um in the 1990s was shutting down a lot
of the work they had been doing for the
previous 80 years like counter Espionage
against Russia which
little premature perhaps nowadays
looking at what's going on and also
cancer version and they were beginning
to move into primarily looking at
counterterrorism you um are basically
given a Target to investigate it could
be a country of Interest it could be a
terrorist organization subversive
organization it could be um an embassy
if you know you're looking for Canter
Espionage work and things like that you
have the target you gather information
and intelligence secret Intelligence on
that Target using a variety of secret
means and then you get all the
information coming in assess it and then
advise on what action to take I mean it
might be drop the investigation there's
no threat or it might be we need to take
action now go in and arrest someone now
because they're about to plant a bomb so
what was your first job assignment in
MI5 you're 22 you're joining what's your
first assignment my first posting was to
a little section called F2 and that was
cancer version I.E MI5 investigating
people for their political beliefs and
political activism within the UK so um
there were hundreds of thousands of
files held on UK citizens for in
members potentially of the Communist
party or trotsky's groups or far-right
groups ni5 became incredibly paranoid
after the Cambridge aspiring Scandal
which was a bunch of establishment types
who betrayed the country in the 1950s
and 60s Burgess philby McLean people
like that so they they got very paranoid
about infiltration and subversion by
particularly the Soviet Union but also
other hostile States
so you've mentioned about your second
posting that it was related to Ira it
was there that I met my former partner
and colleague man who became a very
notorious whistlebler called David
Shaler so I worked there on political
subversion and on Irish terrorism and
also on International terrorism we had
some good results
but there are also mistakes made bombs
that could and should have been
prevented went off on UK streets
innocent people died
which is bad enough but then MI5 refused
to learn from their mistakes
which bombings do you think could have
been prevented uh yeah there was a huge
Lorry Bond called Bishop's gate in 1993.
and MI5 knew about it they bungled the
early investigation into it so it could
have been prevented so your third
posting was investigating International
terrorism
can you explain what were the cases you
you've investigated oh well this was
mainly again going back to David Taylor
because he was the primary Whistler when
we decided to go public about our
concerns
um and he at that time was the head of
the Libyan desk there are three key
cases that we um heard of and witnessed
when we were in G branch in the
international terrorism section first of
all was an illegal telephone tap of a
prominent Guardian journalist and the
second one was a case of a miscarriage
of Justice to Palestinian students based
in London were convicted of conspiracy
to bomb the Israeli Embassy in 1994 and
MI5 had documents which they did not
disclose to the defense and if they had
disclosed the documents
um it's probable that the jury would not
have convicted these two young people
um so they're covered up and continued
cover-up this miscarriage of justice for
many years and in fact the
two students ended up serving 15 years
in prison each as an appalling case but
the the final case and this is why we
actually resigned and why we went public
a Man became known as the Gaddafi
assassination plot this was a case where
MI6 had a walk-in a volunteer who said
that um he had a group of people who
wanted to try and topple Gaddafi in 1996
they needed support from MI5 MI6 and
they needed money and even just Weaponry
to try and affect the coup and MI6
started paying huge amounts money to
this organization and the attack did
indeed go ahead but the explosion had
gone off underneath the wrong car
killing innocent people and also
innocent bystanders as they sort of you
know stood to watch the cavalcade go by
so we did raise a lot of our concerns on
the inside we were told to just shut up
and just follow orders and that's when
we resigned in the mid-1990s to blow the
whistle on a series of spy crimes
it took a while to set up because there
was a mutual distrust between the media
and the Whistleblower so that has to
that trust has to be built up and we
became more more paranoid about how much
we might be being spied on ourselves if
they were getting suspicious about what
we intended to do so we couldn't tell
any of our friends or our family or
anyone give any warning to anyone
having said that for anyone coming out
of the intelligence agencies or central
government or the military you are also
risking prison because you are going to
be automatically breaching the terms of
the official Secrets Act 1989.
so even if you are reporting the spies
um crimes you will be the one who goes
to prison
so knowing that and knowing the risks
we're taking and knowing the fact that
we would become unemployable it meant
that it was a there was a lot of
soul-searching before we took the
decision
um but we felt we had no option but to
try and speak out
so rather than sitting around waiting in
our flat for the knock on the door from
the secret police and being hauled off
to a prison for a couple of years on
remand a waiting trial we decided to
leave the country and went on the run
around Europe for a month
without giving any warning to our
friends and our family so the first they
heard about it was when they saw the
front pages for newspapers and David's
picture sort of smiling out at them
um so that was a huge shock for a lot of
people
so what was your Escape Plan
uh fairly easy assuming that they
weren't already on to us just get the
last flight out of the UK but once in
Europe of course the key thing was to
get through the airports to get into
Europe but once in Europe it was just
using trains
um no cars no flights no airports
nothing so you could just Hop On Hop Off
trains so it was just random traveling
literally across Western Europe for a
month
um disguises only use cash
um never pre-book a hotel
because spies can track you
um yeah so it was very much a sort of
um gamekeeper Turned poacher scenario
because we knew how we would hunt
ourselves if we were investigating us
how did it feel to suddenly effectively
being against UK government and and
being being on the Run
um it was
Going On The Run was a very interesting
experience it actually felt much more
like
um the cliched sort of idea of spy work
than actually working on the inside hat
um we knew that we were being hunted by
the special Branch secret police and
also by MI5
um and we knew how we could try and hide
ourselves but even so
um we were pretty high level targets at
that point so we knew the extent of the
resources they could use against us so
for example
um
the Primitive mobile phones could be
triangulated they could have
um recording devices put in them that
sort of thing uh primitive computers you
know we had to have an old-fashioned
camera stuck on the top rather than
integrated into it could have keystroke
loggers
um could film you remotely it could be
switched on but it was much more
difficult for the spies to implement all
that certainly by the time David and I
were living in Exile in Paris for two
years before he came back to UK we knew
that the flat was probably bugged
electronic communications were bugged
computers phones that sort of thing
um we knew there was a possibility we
might be followed around on the streets
and we also knew there was a possibility
that some of our friends would be
recruited to report back on us or
pressured report back on us and that
turned out to be the case in terms of
our long-term aims though
um we wanted to create a bit of a
scandal and there might be reforms and
tightening up of the laws and the
oversight of the spies that's what we
were aiming for and in order to do that
we needed that bit of a scandal and
we'd sort of thought through what this
spy response would be which was they
would take out gagging orders against
the national media within the first week
which they did which then meant that the
national media got very angry and said
we're the free British press we've got
to have an inquiry into what the spies
are doing so it's all beginning to go
Fairly smoothly
um in terms of working towards what we
wanted to achieve then a week after we
went on the Run
um Princess Diana died in Paris
which sort of Knocked every other piece
of news out of the national media for
weeks and weeks and weeks so we lost all
our protection we lost the head of steam
in terms of the press campaigning for
greater oversight
so we ended up hiding in a remote French
Farmhouse for a year
and then David finally got to the
newspaper and BBC to go public about the
Qaddafi plot which is the main reason
why he wanted to blow the whistle in the
summer of 1998 and immediately he was
arrested when we were in Paris trying to
break the story and thrown into prison
because the British tried and failed to
extradite him from Paris in that summer
he was in prison for about four months
and released because he was deemed to be
a political prisoner
and so we had another two years living
more openly in Exile in Paris and then
he went back voluntarily to face trial
in 2000 eventually after a whole series
of legal hearings was put in front of a
jury in 2002 and
um there is no legal defense on the
official Secrets act for whistleblowing
so he was convicted and sent back to
prison
fortunately though in those days the
Tariff for blowing the whistles two
years in prison per charge what they're
trying to do at the moment for both
whistleblowers and journalists is up
that 14 years in prison per charge which
is huge
um anyway so he served his time he got
out paid his debt to society
um and then we had to try and sort of
rebuild our lives
with no you know career possibilities
um and just after the experiences we'd
had I mean the whole court case took
seven years the whole case took seven
years in total sort of well what do we
do now
um knowing what we know and having
experienced what we experienced so those
were pretty rough years and um
stress kill the relationship as well we
separated in 2006.
did you achieve anything of what you
were planning to well we got a lot of
information out
um so there were various legal cases
including appeals for the two
Palestinians who were wrongfully
convicted
um there was never a proper inquiry into
the Qaddafi plot
um and of course Gaddafi himself
survived and to be assassinated in 2011
by the very same groups backed by the
very same people but by 2011 it was all
done in the glare of the media rather
than in secret but yeah in terms of did
we change anything
I hate to say it I mean for a few years
we gave him a good run for their money
and raised a lot of questions about the
nature of the official Secrets act and
secrecy and privacy and surveillance and
rights and subversion and you know all
that sort of stuff
but it doesn't change anything in the
long term and that's the tragedy I think
for most whistleblowers and particularly
those coming out of intelligence
agencies because the
the mechanism of the sort of the
apparatus of the state will grind on and
on and on and the whistleblowers if
they're lucky Will Survive the process
with their sanity and their Liberty
intact
but very little meaningful change
and everything that is now being
discussed 25 years on is exactly the
sort of stuff that was being discussed
when we were blowing the whistle so
nothing has actually shifted I'm
wondering what the what a whistleblowers
handle like yours would have looked like
nowadays how would it would have been
different I think um the options for
whistleblowers are vastly improved or
have been over the last decade there's
no doubt about it when I first heard
about the Wikileaks publishing model I
thought oh wow oh I wish that had
existed you know 10 years previously
because Wikileaks was set up I think in
2006 2007 and only really hit major
notoriety in 2010 with the Afghan
warlocks
um so there are greater options but also
greater threats I think particularly for
intelligence whistleblowers because
having a high-tech conduit like
Wikileaks where you can anonymously put
information out there
and or then publicly own it gives you
greater control rather than having to go
through the old mainstream media which
is what David and I had to do however
um the power of the surveillance state
is exponentially bigger as well so
unless you've got sort of the tech
skills on a par with some like Edward
Snowden it would probably be virtually
impossible to get
um classified information out there
securely and go on the run preemptively
to try and avoid arrest so um ironically
I think Edward Snowden even his case is
nine years old now 2013 he came out he's
the only other whistlebler I've ever
heard of coming out of the intelligence
agencies who preemptively went on the
run before the story broke
um how you do it now I don't know you
know with all the surveillance many
people talk about Chinese surveillance
Russian State surveillance all the rest
of it but actually what Edward Snowden
revealed a decade ago is the sort of
global panopticon of surveillance that
is run by our Western democracies which
is astonishing
for a nation-state or for a democracy if
everyone within that nation state feels
they don't have sense of privacy they
can't freely discuss or post or write or
have freedom of conscience or whatever
then suddenly that actually becomes a
bit of a police state a bit like East
Germany before the Berlin Wall came down
and that's how democracies
begin to fray and democracy can end and
the slighted towards totalitarianism of
police states can begin
[Music]
within about 30 minutes of us making
that phone call the whole of the area
where we were was infested with starsy
vehicles so it was clear to us that the
phones were all tapped to the British
Embassy